sie kommen damit zum letzten
tagesordnungspunkt heute da geht es um
das vorkaufsrecht in milieus
schutzgebieten hintergrund ist dass das
bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig im
november 2001 und 20 entschieden hat
dass dieses vorkaufsrecht zum beispiel
von bezirk nicht ausgeübt werden kann
weil angenommen wird dass ein käufer die
mieter in zukunft aus dem gebäude aus
dem gebiet verdrängen könnte das reicht
nicht als grund um dieses vorkaufsrecht
auszuüben
und deswegen hat nun die linksfraktion
hier einen antrag eingereicht in dem sie
fordert das ist eine gesetzesänderung
geben muss fordert die bundesregierung
auf hier eine gesetzesänderung
vorzuschlagen damit es dort
rechtssicherheit gibt für kommunen für
städte es gibt auch schon städte die im
bundesrat hier eine initiative
eingebracht haben ein neues
vorkaufsrecht noch einmal
einzubringen erste rednerin ist caren
lay sprechen und für mieten bau und
wohnungspolitik der linksfraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren wir kaufen uns die
stadt zurück das ist das motto vieler
städte im kampf gegen spekulation und
verdrängung alleine in berlin konnten
mit hilfe dieses so genannten
vorkaufsrechts schon
2700 wohnungen zurückgekauft werden für
9000 weitere soziale standards
vereinbart werden das ist ein
erfolgsmodell das bundesweit schule
machen sollte
und wenig städte sind im beispiel schon
gefolgt münchen hamburg und köln haben
das vorkaufsrecht für sich entdeckt zur
freude der mieterinnen und mieter denn
ganz ehrlich wer würde nicht lieber
günstig und sicher bei der stadt wohnen
statt eine ominöse briefkastenfirma oder
einen hedgefonds als vermieter zu haben
denn das bedeutet häufig mieterhöhung
kündigung und verträgen und das wollen
wir als linke nicht
der immobilien lobbyist es vorkaufsrecht
herr fürst natürlich ein dorn im auge
und deswegen ist sie vors gericht
gezogen und leider hat das
bundesverwaltungsgericht in den recht
gegeben und unser baugesetzbuch so
interpretiert dass das vorkaufsrecht
fragt sich nur noch daran gezogen werden
kann wenn die immobilie praktisch leer
steht oder baufällig ist aber die
kommunen können jetzt nicht mehr kaufen
wenn die verdrängung zukünftig droht
aber das ist doch absurd genau darum
geht es doch meine damen und herren
das vorkaufsrecht ist damit faktisch tot
es ist ein schlag ins gesicht der
mieterinnen und mieter und damit dürfen
wir uns nicht abfinden
allein in berlin sind 600 wohnungen
direkt vom urteil betroffen und in
münchen sind seit der urteilsverkündung
schon über 220 wohnungen verkauft worden
viele weitere häuser hängen in der
schwebe also etwa dort wo das
vorkaufsrecht noch beklagt wird
zehntausende mieterinnen und mieter
müssen jetzt angst haben und die
kommunen sind praktisch machtlos gegen
den ausverkauf der stadt das finde ich
schrecklich jetzt sind wir gefragt der
bundestag muss diesen fehler im gesetz
sofort korrigieren
und diese chance wobei der letzten
novelle des baugesetzbuches leider
verteilen es gab hinweise im aus dem
bundesrat die von der vorgängerregierung
hinweggegangen wurden doch auch die
ampel hätte längst handeln können im
koalitionsvertrag lese ich nur es gibt
einen prüfauftrag also ich bitte sie mit
einem einzigen paragrafen so was gehört
in ein 100 tage programm
und auch der überlinger bausenator
geisel von der spd gebiet irische vor
ein paar tagen mit der aussage die
korrektur würde jetzt noch ein bis zwei
jahre dauern also ehrlich gesagt bis
dahin sind die häuser längst verkauft
solange können mieterinnen und mieter
nicht warten bundesweit demonstrieren
menschen gegen die abschaffung faktische
abschaffung des vorkaufsrecht gestern in
münchen heute morgen vor dem reichstag
wir als linke fordern mit ihnen
gemeinsam ein neues vorkaufsrecht jetzt
bitte stimmen sie für unseren antrag das
gemeinwohl muss vorrang profit profit
haben die kommunen müssen vorrang vor
spekulanten haben vielen dank
das wort hat die kollegin claudia
tausend für die spd
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das urteil des
bundesverwaltungsgerichts leipzig am 9
november hat uns komplett überrascht
dass und damals in den
koalitionsverhandlungen mit den partnern
von grünen und fdp aber wir sind noch in
den koalitionsverhandlungen tätig
geworden wir haben nämlich aufgenommen
endenden vertrag zu prüfen ob sich aus
diesem urteil ein gesetzgeberischer
handlungsbedarf für uns ergibt nämlich
dann wenn die urteilsbegründung vorliegt
prüfungen prüfung haben wir deshalb
gesagt weil zu diesem zeitpunkt am 9
november gab es eine dürre
pressemitteilung des gerichtes wir
wussten nicht bezieht sich das urteil
auf die beklagten sonderfall in berlin
oder erlangt dass allgemeingültigkeit
für alle kommunen hier in deutschland
mittlerweile wissen wir das ist der fall
der neunten november war ein
einschneidender tag für die kommunen
aber natürlich für alle mieter mieter
und eine immerhin liebe caren lay 35
jahre unbeanstandete rechtsauffassung
ist gekippt wurden dieses gesetz geht
zurück ins jahr 1986 damals waren an der
regierung nicht beteiligt und ist
wirklich 35 jahre in den unteren
instanzen bestätigt wurden hat zu einer
ausübung der vorkaufsrechte geführt wie
zurecht dargestellt worden ist war ein
geübte praxis wir waren völlig
überrascht
auch beim bauland mobilisierungs gesetz
kann ich dir sagen kann ich ihnen sagen
mir als berichterstatterin ist zu keinem
zeitpunkt ein hinweis erteilt worden
dass hier ein handlungsbedarf bestehen
würde die gesetzesinitiative
des landes berlin ist irgendwo liegen
geblieben vielleicht im bundestag oder
in akten und liebe karin neipp von euch
kam auch kein hinweis obwohl ja immer
sehr sehr würdig sein
schlussendlich müssen wir wir müssen
tätig werden wir müssen tätig werden das
hat uns das bundesverwaltungsgericht
aufgegeben nämlich hier auch den
gesetzestext klar zu stellen und zwar
wortlaut vor dem hintergrund neuer
entwicklungen und drängenden problemen
auf dem wohnungsmarkt und wir wissen
alle die wir im ausschuss sind unsere
frau bundesbauministerium klare derzeit
in der aller ersten ausschusssitzung
bereits klargestellt dieses thema wird
das haus wird ministerin persönlich mit
aller absoluter priorität verfolgen und
zu einem gesonderten verfahren nicht
angehängt an den neu große baugesetzbuch
novelle wir alle wissen wir brauchen
schnell rechtssicherheit um die menschen
weiter für gentrifizierung und
verdrängung aus den angestammten
wohnungen dem wohnumfeld schützen zu
können
wir nehmen nicht hin ja dass eines der
wichtigsten instrumente des
mieterschutzes entfällt das dem schutz
komplett durchlöchert wird dass die
ausübung des vorkaufsrechts auf
städtebauliche missstände auch
schrottimmobilien reduziert wird wir
wollen auch dem ausverkauf der städte
nicht zuschauen wir wollen unsere
kommunen ausdrücklich stärken und wir
nehmen alle appelle und demonstrationen
kann auch an einer unterschätzten abgabe
der initiative teilnehmen dürfen sehr
sehr ernst die mietervereine macht uns
aufmerksam dass städter tat natürlich
die hauptbetroffenen kommunen meine
zurecht dargestellt münchen gehört dazu
an der spitze gemeinsam mit hamburg und
berlin und es haben hier zahllose
schreiben erreicht und der wirbel die
mieterinnen und mieter nicht im regen
stehen lassen das wünscht dabei spielen
muss ich nicht anführen das hat mir
caren lay vorweggenommen deswegen kann
ich zum schluss kommen die
bauministerkonferenz und viele weitere
bälle haben uns erreicht aufgefordert
aufgefordert zügig diesem gesetzentwurf
vorzulegen mittlerweile sogar auch der
freistaat bayern und diese kleine
bemerkung sein wir noch erlaubt das
freut mich besonders noch mehr liebe csu
will dass mich freuen wenn sie den
bieten litern in bayern helfen bündelt
indem sie den paragrafen 250 des neuen
baugesetzbuches nämlich das allgemeine
umwandlungs verbot in kraft setzen
würden das sind noch einige hausaufgaben
in bayern zu erledigen in anderen
bundesländern leider auch ich komme zum
schluss
sie rennen mit ihrem antrag liebe
linkspartei offene türen ein wir
brauchen keine weiteren aufforderungen
der anzug ist eigentlich überflüssig
aber unschädlich ermöglicht weitere
debatte wir alle wissen der
gesetzentwurf wird derzeit erarbeitet es
gilt gründlichkeit vor schnelligkeit wir
wollen mit dem neuen gesetz nicht wieder
beanstandet werden sondern dauerrecht
sicherheitschefs verändert zum schluss
im meter und für die stärkung unserer
kommunen wir werden deswegen ihren
antwort überweisen
der
abgeordnete claudia tausend und so wurde
es auch schon angefreundet in hamburg
und münchen haben eine gemeinsame
initiative gestartet
jetzt kommt sagt das ergebnis der
abstimmung zum bundeswehr einsatz
wir kommen zum ergebnis der namentlichen
abstimmung zu dem antrag der
bundesregierung fortsetzung des
einsatzes bewaffneter deutscher
streitkräfte
stabilisierung sichern wieder erstarken
des verhindern versöhnung in ihrer
fördern
abgegebene stimmkarten
666 mit jahr haben 5 155 abgeordnete
gestimmt mit nein stimmten
110 abgeordnete es gab eine enthaltung
die beschlussempfehlung ist
das bedeutet
bundeswehr- einsatz im irak wird
fortgesetzt nächster redner jetzt hier
zum vorkaufsrecht ist lars rohwer es ist
seine erste rede für die unionsfraktion
glückauf frau präsidentin und meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren die linke im
hohen haus fordert mieterinnen und
mieter vor verdrängung zu schützen den
mietanstieg zu stoppen und sozialen
zusammenhalt zu stärken
im mittel ist dafür der milieus und das
kommunale vorkaufsrecht es ist aber
genau der milieu schutz den das
bundesverfassungsgericht in leipzig im
november weitgehend gekippt hat das in
berlin übliche vorkaufsrecht von
grundstücken aus gründen des milieus
dürfe nicht auf der basis der annahme
ausgeübt werden dass der andere käufer
die mieter in zukunft mutmaßlich aus dem
gebiet verdrängen möchte
fragen sie sich eigentlich ob die
zurückbeordern der milch schutz satzung
tatsächlich das geeignete politische
mittel ist um ihre forderung gegen
gentrifizierung und verdrängung in der
unsere metropolen zum erfolg zu
verhelfen
fraulein schön wenn man sich mal wieder
sieht sie wissen ich vertrete einen
wahlkreis wo gorbitz dazugehört dresden
gorbitz und ich sage ihnen ich bin bei
ihnen das ist eine durchmischung eine
gesunde durchmischung sozialer schichten
in den unterschiedlichen teilen anderer
stattgeben muss ich meine jedoch dass
die hier genau das falsche instrument
aus dem werkzeugkasten auswählen wollen
denn ja verdrängung finde zu unserem
bedauern stadt aber finden sie mit einem
milieu schutz so nicht mehr statt
mitnichten zur verdeutlichung
möchte ich sie auf einen denkfehler
hinweisen unterstützen mit einem milieu
schutz satzung kein milieu sondern
negative städtebauliche entwicklung zur
veranstaltung wenn reiche familien arme
familien in einem kiez verdrängen spielt
es für die generelle auslastung der
grundschule überhaupt keine rolle ein
weiterer denkanstoß erhalten wir mit
einer mediation tatsächlich die
bezahlbare hoffentlich bald energetische
sanierung der wohnung oder erfüllen wir
mit million schutz die aufforderung nach
kleinen eigentumswohnungen aus dem
bestand als staatlich beworbene form der
altersvorsorge für junge menschen
was ich sagen will ist wir benötigen
mehrdimensionales handeln und nicht
unbedingt abwendung bescheidet die
enorme teils unsinnige verpflichtungen
für wohneigentümer mit sich bringen
milieu
schutz sollte die absolute ausnahme sein
und nicht über ganze stadtkerne
übergestülpt werden
bei jeder op im gesundheitsbereich
wünschen wir uns minimal invasive
eingriffe mit maximaler wirkung nehmen
wir uns daran als gesetzgeber im bereich
bauen und wurden ein beispiel der milieu
schutz ist in seiner jetzigen form
wirkungslos erhält die städtebauliche
veränderung nicht auf dementiert
vielmehr soziale strukturen
problemviertel und schafft ein
ungleichgewicht auf den markt in der
theorie erscheint es als probates mittel
und mitte mieterinnen und mieter vor
luxussanierung zu schützen in der praxis
hat das instrument versagt
das vorkaufsrecht von kommunen zum
bauland und wohnraum hat keinen
lindernden effekt auf das marktgeschehen
es besteht sogar die gefahr dass diese
boten politischen aktivitäten höhere
kaufpreise provozieren die kommune baut
in der regel viele wohnungen für wenig
geld eine wohnung gleicht dann der
anderen individualität geht völlig
verloren robert musil hat einmal gesagt
ich mag wurden und nicht leiten die
seelisch nach maß geschnitten sind
soziale brennpunkte entstehen bereits
mit dem zeichen der grundrisse der
milieus zementiert ein ungleichgewicht
dem markt und hält die veränderungen auf
die soziale durchmischung findet nicht
mehr statt und das ist denke ich nicht
die intention des gesetzgebers
der mérieux schütz muss daher die
absolute ausnahme bleiben vorkaufsrechte
der kommunen werden in der regel nicht
umgesetzt es besteht also keine
notwendigkeit sie wieder einzuführen um
die probleme auf dem wohnungsmarkt in
großstädten wie münchen berlin und
hamburg zu lösen brauchen wir weniger
staatliche eingriffe und mehr team wird
aus kommune gute analysten und
investoren dabei müssen wir
mit genauen augenmaß und sachverstand
herangehen politische regulierungen
helfen hier in meinen augen nicht weiter
lassen sie uns nicht an maßnahmen
festhalten die nicht zu dem gewünschten
ziel führen
vorkaufsrecht und abfindungsvereinbarung
reifen pauschal in eigentumsrechte 1 sie
schützen keine mieterinnen und mieter
dauerhaft und helfen nicht problemlosen
zu lösen wir lehnen den antrag der
linksfraktion ab
lars huber war das der baustadtrat in
friedrichshain kreuzberg hat das
vorkaufsrecht in den vergangenen fünf
jahren rund 800 bei rund 800 wohnungen
angewandt also sehr oft und die nächste
rednerin kommt aus diesem wahlkreis
canan bayram für die grünen ist jetzt
hier am redner.de frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in meinem
wahlkreis für design kreuzberg und
prenzlauer berg ost in berlin gibt es
sehr viele menschen die auf und hoffen
die auf und bauen und die auf dieses
gesetz warten wir müssen das
baugesetzbuch so ändern dass das
vorkaufsrecht gerichtsfest und
rechtssicher wieder möglich ist meine
damen und herren
und da hilft es nichts weder von der
einen noch von der anderen seite den
eindruck erwecken zu wollen man wolle
nicht oder man könne nicht nein meine
damen und herren wir wollen das
vorkaufsrecht wir werden es stärken und
wir werden damit die mieterinnen und
mieter schützen das haben wir uns
vorgenommen
denn eins ist doch klar was heißt denn
die eigene wohnung das ist doch nicht
nur das dach über dem kopf was einen
schützt wo die wohnung liegt davon hängt
auch der kita platz ab die nachbarschaft
die soziale infrastruktur und auch die
mischung gerade in berlin sprechen wir
immer von der berliner mischung das
unterschiedliche menschen in
unterschiedlichen berufen mit
unterschiedlichen einkommen ganz
selbstverständlich nebeneinander leben
und das repräsentieren was wir hier
gemeinsam auch im sinne einer demokratie
schützen wollen dazu dient das milieu
schutz meine damen und herren und
deswegen wollen wir es erhalten und ich
kann auch wirklich in jede richtung die
zweifel am vorkaufsrechts führen will
sagen was soll der in der stadt machen
wenn er sich selbst dieses instrument
aus der hand schlägt gegen diejenigen
vermieterinnen und vermieter die wir
alle kennen die das gemeinwohl nicht im
blick haben die artikel führt sie nicht
so genau gelesen haben wo nämlich
drinsteht eigentum verpflichtet und wer
eine wohnung hat der soll sich
gefälligst den menschen anbieten damit
die auch wohnen können denn für ich es
klar wohnen ist keine ware wohnen müssen
wir alle meine damen und herren
und von daher gilt wir werden das
gründlich miteinander beraten wir werden
einen vorschlag vorlegen der vor
gerichten bestand hat und damit werden
wir sicherstellen dass das vorkaufsrecht
das bleibt was es vor dieser
gerichtsentscheidung des
bundesverwaltungsgerichts war nämlich
ein stadtentwicklungs politisches
instrument mit dem mieterinnen vor
verdrängung vorzertifizierung geschützt
werden vielen dank
bayram war das für die grünen hier im
bundestag nächste rednerin in der
debatte ist carolin bachmann es ist ihre
erste rede der afg fraktions des afg
fraktionsmitglieds
frau präsidentin werte kollegen sehr
geehrte damen und herren wir
beschäftigen uns heute mit einem antrag
der linken zum kommen ein vorkaufsrecht
in müs gebieten aber um was geht es ein
investor möchte ein haus erwerben es
renovieren und auf vordermann bringen
eigentlich etwas schönes doch die linken
sehen im investor grundsätzlich ein
geldgierigen immobilienhai sie wollen
die ausübung des vorkaufsrechts durch
kommunen bereits bei verdacht auf
erhaltungs widrige nutzungs absichten
einführen jedoch ignorieren sie das
urteil des bundesverwaltungsgericht vom
november letzten jahres
besteht bereits rechtssicherheit ihr
antrag offenbart gestörtes verhältnis
zur rechtssprechung und damit zum
rechtsstaat
was würde sich am wohnungsmarkt
eigentlich ändern wenn wir ihren antrag
beschließen würden würde sich das
verhältnis zwischen angebot und
nachfrage ändern nein würde das von
ihnen geforderte milieus häuser im glanz
erstrahlen lassen nein
wer wissen will wie sich die
verstaatlichung von immobilien auf den
wohnungsbestand auswirkt das sollte eine
reise ins sozialistischen kuba buchen
ihre falsche auslegung des
vorkaufsrechts trifft wieder den
steuerzahler und schafft keinen
quadratmeter wohnraum und stabilisiert
die mieten nicht
die eigentliche frage ist
deshalb steht der wohnungsmarkt in den
städten unter druck es gibt drei
hauptursachen erstens immer mehr einer
zwei personen wohnungen werden
nachgefragt
zweitens die menschen fliehen am land
von vom land in die städte und drittens
die unkontrollierte zuwanderung erhöht
die nachfrage zusätzlich
doch wer sind die bedürftigen die auf
günstigen wohnraum angewiesen sind das
sind die alleinerziehenden eltern das
sind die vereinsamten großeltern und das
sind die gering- und mittelverdiener
und ihre lösung soll der milieus sein
wie viele milieu schutzgebiete wollen
sie denn zukünftig in deutschland
ausreichen um allen bedürftigen zu
helfen
wollen sie wirklich dass der staat haus
um haus aufkauft bis vier kubanische
verhältnisse haben
während sie rot grüne luftschlösser
bauen und von günstigen wohnraum träumen
verhindern sie investitionen und
erschaffen sozialistische bruchbuden
vorliege kollegen muss für alle
bezahlbar sein ich erwarte von
politikern genau wie von ärzten erst die
richtige diagnose und dann die richtige
therapie doktor sie nicht weiter an den
symptomen herum gehen sie den
hauptursachen endlich auf den grund
die fdp bekennt sich zur sozialen
marktwirtschaft und zum
investitionsschutz wir wollen die
hauptursachen der wohnungsnot lösen sie
nicht vielen dank
herr bachmann war das ein nächster
redner ist rainer sehm at erst der
kommunalpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion im
deutschen bundestag hat nun der
abgeordnete rainer sehm mit für die fdp
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kollegen sehr geehrte damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen natürlich auch es ist
mir eine freude und eine ehre hier meine
erste rede halten zu dürfen das thema
bauen und wohnen begleitet nicht mein
ganzes berufsleben wir haben hier eine
sehr hitzige diskussion ich möchte
deshalb vielleicht einen anderen aspekt
ja auch mit in den vordergrund rücken um
das etwas zu relativieren
die situation auf dem wohnungsmarkt ist
prekär nicht nur in großstädten wie
berlin münchen oder stuttgart auch in
kleineren städten wie meine heimatstadt
pforzheim
ist der wohnungsmarkt leergefegt dies
führt natürlich zu überhöhten preisen
warum
die antwort ist schlicht und einfach wir
haben zu wenig wohnraum
neben der diskussion die hier so heftig
geführt wird angebot und nachfrage sind
nicht ausgeglichen die folge eine
bezahlbare wohnung zu finden ist für
menschen mit niedrigem einkommen
fast unmöglich und selbst für menschen
mit besserem einkommen eine
herausforderung wenn ich mit kommunalen
vertreterinnen und vertretern sprecher
höre ich auf zwei hauptproblemen es gibt
nicht genügend fläche zu bebauen grund
es dauert zu lange bis endlich gebaut
werden kann dies ist ein klarer auftrag
an den gesetzgeber wohl wo wir jetzt die
ganze zeit gesprochen haben ist über die
auslegung eines gesetzes seit lauter
seit langer zeit existiert als
regierungsfraktionen haben wir das klare
ziel im koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten 400.000 neue wohnungen pro
jahr die bausubstanz bestehende gebäude
verbessern und das bauen klimaneutraler
attraktiver und weniger bürokratisch
gestalten
wir haben wir haben in der ampel
beschlossen dieses das
bundesverwaltungsgerichts urteil zu
überprüfen die überprüfung steht an und
ist angekündigt und wird stattfinden
symbolpolitik mit diesem antrag ist hier
völlig fehl am platz
es ist ein prüfauftrag
[Musik]
ja es geht aber um einen prüfauftrag wir
haben schon eingesetzt
nur sauber ausgearbeitete konkrete
gesetze bieten rechtssicherheit und
halten auch der künftigen prüfung vor
gerichten stand vor schnell
verabschiedet die gesetze hingegen wie
der
verfassungswidrige mieten deckel in
berlin für einen letzter instanz nur zu
noch höheren kosten auf seiten der
mieterinnen und mieter auch wir halten
es für nötig den kommunalen ein
weitgehendes recht zur gestaltung an die
hand zu geben hierbei sollte jedoch
neben dem erhalt gewachsener strukturen
auch der blick auf zukünftiges wohnen
gerichtet sein
die überarbeitung des
baugesetzbuchs § 26 04 wird das wohnungs
und bau problem alleine nicht lösen viel
wichtiger ist dass vor allem der bau
neuer wohnungen befördert wird die muss
auch erwähnt werden dass der weitaus
größere anteil der investitionen im
wohnungsbau von privaten investoren
bereit gestellt wird und nicht von der
öffentlichen hand
die ausübung eines vorkaufsrecht
bedeutet immer auch für die kommune dass
sie die instandhaltung und sanierung
für sanierungsmaßnahmen der zukunft
tragen muss wir halten es für notwendig
dass ein rahmen geschaffen wird in
welchen kommunen und private investoren
gemeinsame projekte entwickeln können um
so möglichst vielen neuen wohnraum
realisieren zu können
gerade in dieser frage scheint das aber
noch reichlich gesprächsbedarf zu geben
dies gilt übrigens auch für die
geschichte in den großstädten und der
erhaltungssatzung wir bleiben also dabei
gute gesetze brauchen zeit werden nicht
mit heißer nadel gestrickt sie sollen
zielgerichtet und zukunftssicher sein
und sie sollen sich dauerhaft positiv
auf das leben der bürgerinnen und bürger
auswirken das ist der stil den wehren
der ampel vereinbart haben
lassen sie uns deshalb gemeinsam über
das für und wider des vorkaufsrechts
ausführlich im ausschuss diskutieren
herzlichen dank
rainer siebert war das jetzt ein
vorkaufsrecht und das thema wohnen wird
dem bundestag wo noch das ein oder
andere mal beschäftigen auch der
bundesrat will sich nun damit
auseinandersetzen
zumindest nach wunsch von berlin unter
anderem und die wohnungspolitik wird
unter anderem auch in der nächsten
sitzungswoche thema sein die startet am
14 februar auch wird es dort um
bundeswehreinsätze oder das
arbeitsprogramm der europäischen
kommission gehen wir verlassen für heute
die debatte im deutschen parlament aber
sind natürlich dann auch in der nächsten
sitzungswoche weiter dabei